sept jours c'est le pas qui nous restent
avant la famille hmong ekoko
nous sommes toujours sans nouvelles de
pas w à votre seul espoir face à la
menace de la lune rouge s'est volatilisé
aux enfants ils disent que vous êtes le
seul qui pourra nous sauver paul wrc
vous pas vrai
paul
qu'est ce que tu veux faire cette fois
c'est à toi de me faire confiance
tu peux pas rester réellement c'est trop
dangereux
si je reste avec nous je voulais
retrouver papa
salut petit frère
qui soit fiable
c'est ce à quoi tu a infléchi une fois
que ça peut être bien
la lune rouge c'est pas la première fois
que sa trajectoire processeur de la
terre
chaque fois ça correspond à des
bouleversements
j'étais aveugle ou quoi c'est pas une
coïncidence
[Musique]